hi my name is Andrea Griffin and I'm
going to talk about all from tech and
online courses that are LTI compatible
like EDX Coursera and Moodle
my name is Kyle Keene I will talk
briefly and heard a little bit of
feedback day I will talk briefly to give
a big picture of what we've been doing
and then Andrea Griffin is my colleague
at MIT she's a research engineer who's
been building out tooling to help
connect Wolfram language and Wolfram
language cloud objects into online
courses in a way that allows them to
inject grades back into the online
course so this has been kind of a big
stopping point for a lot of people who
want to use Wolfram in online courses
but they need to use the gradebook
that's provided by the software so now
we've solved that problem at least for
ourselves that I might see with EDX is
platform and it should be transferable
to anybody else yeah so that's I think
my big picture and I'm gonna hand it off
to Andrea and I'll be back in 30 minutes
to talk about other stuff yes so thanks
Val so I'm basically gonna walk through
the package that we made that just
interacts with learning tools interrupt
your interoperability which I can never
say right the first time which gives a
bunch of functionality to things that
you might be looking for we have online
courses and then eventually be able to
send grades to the platform so Kyle and
I have been working with two different
courses at MIT one is called launching
innovation in schools and the other is
the MIT 801 X mechanics kinematics and
dynamics courses they asked for a few
different projects in both of those
courses so I'm going to walk through
each of the projects and by walking
through each of the projects I'll walk
through some of the functions that I've
been using for the for the projects that
are that you can find in the package the
package is open so I'll also show how
you guys can tap into it it's obviously
still in development so you know have a
little bit of have a little bit of a
flexibility with it but it's it's
working and good and we're liking it so
so my first example here is
basically imagine something that you
want to just show up and you in the
online course you don't want to show you
don't want to also show up in just on
the web so this is an example online
course here that I have this text here
that's very small on the screen but it
says this will only be seen within the
course and it's very true so if I go to
that link outside of the course it gives
me this failure messages so sorry you're
not in the course you're not a part of
the course you shouldn't see this thing
and so yeah so we're able to now just
show things as long as you are
authenticated within the course and I do
that just by using this function called
LTI verifier request and so you're
seeing this it's just a cloud object
delayed cloud object where we get this
LTI package and verify that they are
within the course and if they are then
they move on and see this the rest of
the third object so you can imagine in
your course maybe you want to take a
poll of the students there and you don't
want students from outside the course to
interact with this poll so you can set
this up in that same way where you have
LTI there verify request and then you
have some forum function as your cloud
object and you have a data bin you
submit that information to a dative and
make a bar chart and so within the
course have this started somewhere else
within the course you can have this poll
that just shows what's your favorite
flavor of ice cream and you can pick
your favorite flavor submit it and see a
bar chart of all the other student
submissions and because of the way that
learning tools interoperability works we
have to pass some information from the
we have to pass some information as we
go along through the process and when
you hit submit on a form it brings you
to a second page so that's one thing
that we cracked is making sure that we
pass all that information to the
following pages that
long so you can just use LTI launch form
so this is a second cloud object that
comes before and we just use LTI launch
form to make sure that the form is going
to pass all the data that needs to be
passed through okay so onto the real
projects that we were working on so this
launching innovations in schools course
is is on EDX a the teacher there asked
that we make an artefact generator they
wanted the students to at the beginning
of the course make a course plan so they
wanted them to reflect on when they
would work on the course what their
goals are stuff like that before the
course started so we made them this
artifact generator zoom in a little here
this artifact generator where they can
type in a bunch of information they can
pick their goals they can add another
goal they can say who they want to share
the course with they pick some time that
they would be working on the course and
add some goals and they can also add an
image and then they fill out the form
and it makes a nice little PDF for them
to then like maybe post near their desk
where they're going to work or something
like that and one of the great things
about how this works is now if i refresh
this page i can go back and get all of
the information that i had before
already saved in the forum and i can go
back and could submit and change the
information that I already had and we
did all of that without making them sign
into the Wolfram cloud because they've
already signed in to the course and we
can get that information through the
interoperability functionality so the
way that we do that is that there's a
function in a package that we've called
get user ID so basically I get the
hashed version of their authentication
to the course
and I can identify them within the
course using the user ID and I store
their information like all of the things
that they put into the form into a cloud
object that is found given their user ID
so sitting on my cloud right now there
are these folders with hash user IDs and
within each of these I have the info
that they submitted into the form and
their picture and then when I want them
to return back to the form I just say do
they have anything from info that
they've already submitted and if they
don't don't put anything in the fields
and if they do put it in the fields so
we can collect all the information that
they've done before and show it again so
then this brings me to the next project
that the launching innovation Schools
teacher asked us to work on was to make
a gallery they have their students
submit they have them think about what a
powerful learning environment might be
and create an image that represents what
a powerful learning environment is and
then submit the image and the teacher
wanted them all to be able to see all of
the images in one place and interact
with and talk about them and in just in
a separate discussion forum but then
they also had other reasons for having
students submit images and then see them
all in one collected place so this is a
tool that they wanted in multiple places
without there wasn't within their course
so rather than making them totally
different cloud objects for every for
every submission what I did was we came
up with a function called resource link
ID so again within LTI the system knows
where in the course you are so every
every every object in the in the course
has an identifier and so we use that
identifier to come up with what sorry to
show a different object and it will
submit information to a different place
so just like with the user ID I then
submit all the information that they put
in
to the forum I give it the resource link
ID as one of the objects in the path and
then it it knows exactly where the
information is coming from if it is this
object within the course or if is this
object or it's a different one a totally
different place so sitting on my cloud
again I have these resource link ID
folders that then point to data and a
separate gallery for just that for just
that instance of the gallery and then
within the data is the same thing as we
saw before where there's a bunch of
folders with the user IDs and inside
that there's information and pictures
now we we got to a point in the
discussion with this teacher that we
were concerned about students posting
something quote bad and we wanted the
teacher to be able to delete posts so
this is an example of what the gallery
looks like to the students once they've
submitted something to the gallery and
this is actually live that went live on
Monday so I was happy to see that there
are some there but then the teacher when
they come to the course in the same
place where the student would see the
gallery the teacher sees this which I'm
sure is and so they get to see all of
the submissions but then there's a small
little delete button here and the way
that we're able to do that is we can
switch between a staff and learner view
so again through the LTI functionality
we know what role they are and so I can
say give me the teachers role if they
are an administrator or an instructor
show the administrative view and if they
are a student then send them to either
the form or the gallery if they have or
haven't submitted yet so you can see
here this is what the learner sees it
goes straight to the forum and this is
what the staff sees where they have the
ability to delete a post if they see
something that they don't want to see
okay so then in this mechanics and
kinematics and dynamics course we've
basically started to interject a bunch
of Wolfram functionality into this
course you can see here we've injected a
manipulate we've actually started to
teach the course how to use coding
within the course Kyle I think is going
to talk about that more it's a part of a
bigger research study at MIT that's now
possible because of some of these the
functionality here and what we have done
here is we've given the students a
problem and then we have a form down
here where they submit their answer and
if they are able to submit so they
submit an answer and because of this
function called send grade we just use
this one quick little thing here with
what their grades should be from zero to
one and then we've also passed along
some keys and it will grade their work
and then also submit their grade to the
course so I'll try this again and I'll
actually try to get it correct so I'll
get I'll get one right how about that
and so this should send fifty percent to
the course and I should get my five
points if i refresh the page and so just
by adding this one little line here
we've added sending grades straight to
the course as long as you have the
package uploaded as well okay so and
then the next thing we noticed was
within this course there as they're
doing their problems they're going to
ask us questions and so they need to be
able to send us questions so we added a
discussion section where they can submit
a question or something like that
actually last night someone submitted
the answer so it's a run in and delete
it you can see the rules are coming up
here where I have the operator I have
the opportunity to
and this student has an opportunity to
delete their own post if they need to
and so when a student submits a post it
sends an email to Kyle and I and it also
includes their email in the email to us
so that we can respond back to them
directly if we need to so again we get
their email through this LTI
functionality in this function called
get email and then we're able to respond
back to them just through their email
instead of coming back to the discussion
post if we if it's something that
doesn't need to be shared with the rest
of the the rest of the group so are our
bonus project that we're working on is a
research study that will be on talking
about what we're we're doing with some
of these interactions in the 801 X
course where we're injecting some coding
and basically trying coding and
computation using visualizations to
determine if adding these things into
the course is in fact helpful or not to
the learning of the students and if and
how it changes their learning and we're
able to do that with some of this LTI
functionality on the online courses now
we were able to cohort the students and
use their user IDs to feed them
different ways of instructing them on
these things so that's about as much as
I have I'm so I'm open for questions